Speaker 1: Welcome to The David Pakman Show,
I am Jesse Dalibor, sitting in for David while
he's on vacation.
Listen, we got a problem with conspiracy theories
in the United States.
It's no longer a fringe element that believes
that 9/11 was an inside job or or that we
didn't land on the moon or or any number of
disparate conspiracy conspiracy theories.
Yeah, the Republican Party is in large measure
led and motivated by conspiracy theories.
It is the north star of the Grand Old Party
anymore.
And that is evidenced by their push against
science, their disregard for the health and
welfare of their fellow Americans and their
families.
And I want to talk a little bit about Marjorie
Taylor Green.
But before I do, I get a lot of flack on my
own channel for talking about Donald Trump
and and Marjorie Taylor Green and some of
these other Kuhnen adherents and conspiracy
nutters.
And I believe it is important because conspiracy
is what led to the insurrection at the United
States Capitol.
Conspiracy and lies and propaganda is what
led to over one hundred and fifty police officers
being injured, some of them losing fingers,
obviously, some of them losing their lives.
So to ignore these characters is to bury our
heads in the sand.
And just hope that it doesn't happen again.
I, for one, am not prepared to do that.
I will continue.
To talk about these dangerous individuals
in our country, as long as they exist now,
let's talk about.
The lovely and talented Marjorie Taylor Green,
who is now suspended from Twitter.
But still finds places to go to talk about
her insanity.
Real America's voice, I have been called a
not a real American many times, this is the
what I suffer through.
I've chosen this profession and I'm going
to be attacked by wingnuts.
That's what it is.
But to have a network, that's real America's
voice.
It indicates that there are fake Americans.
And I've been called that.
Anyway, let's get to this Marjorie Taylor
Green clip where she rambles for roughly a
minute and forty five seconds incoherently
at times.
Speaker 2: So this is concerning to me.
And that's why I'm saying there's more research
needed by the FDA before the FDA approves
these vaccines, because here's the problem.
Once the vaccines are approved by the FDA,
FDA, we are going to see the mandates for
vaccines ramp up far more than they are right
now.
They're going to be mandated and I fear they'll
become law in some cities.
In some states, Biden would love to make it
the law of the land.
Speaker 1: Biden would love to make it the
law of the land that everyone is healthy and
their welfare is is attended to.
That's a fear she doesn't fear that people
are dying of covid-19, she doesn't fear that
children are now at higher risk.
She doesn't fear that our hospitals are even
filling up.
She'll get to that here in a minute.
She fears that more people will get the vaccine.
That was an unhinged thought process,
Speaker 2: and I think that's completely wrong.
Again, I'm not an tiebacks.
I am completely for people being allowed to
make choices, medical choices for themselves
and their families and.
Speaker 1: When you're anti vax just claiming
you're not anti Vax doesn't get it done.
Margie.
You have to actually be pro vaccine, there's
not middle ground, it's like I don't know
how I feel about it.
When you go on network after network and you
go on Twitter, where you have to be suspended
because of your disinformation campaign.
Promoting anti vaccine ideas.
That's what makes you anti vaccine.
Speaker 2: And I don't think the FDA should
approve a vaccine that doesn't seem to be
that effective, especially with covid-19 raging
all over the country.
At least that's what the media tells us every
single day.
Speaker 1: All right.
I didn't mean I wasn't wanting to stop and
start this march, but listen.
Two things here.
She's claiming that the media is claiming
that covid-19 is raging all over the country.
It is true, we have statistics, we know what
the numbers are, we know what the hospitalization
rates are, we know what the infection rates
are, we know how many tests are being tested.
But to to to ignore the fact that the reason
covid-19 is out breaking everywhere across
the country, especially in certain states,
Arkansas, Louisiana, Florida, is because of
people like you, Marjorie Taylor Greene, who
are encouraging people not to get the vaccine.
It is overwhelmingly non vaccinated individuals
who are being hospitalized and who are dying
still.
Of the coronavirus.
It is irresponsible.
It's shameful.
This is shameful, what we're witnessing in
this country, the mismanagement by Republican
governors and being being bolstered by by
clowns like this.
Speaker 2: But I've talked to local hospitals
here in my district and here in my state.
Yes.
That the waiting rooms get full.
But guess what?
The waiting rooms are full of all kinds of
things, not just health, car accidents, trauma
or other illnesses, cancer and so forth, but
they're seeing about 30 percent of those numbers
being the cases.
So while the news tries to tell us the hospitals
are slammed, packed with Kevin, that's just
not the case.
Everyone needs to get back down, back down
to common sense.
And remember that, you know, we're human.
We can't live forever.
We are going to catch all kinds of diseases
and all kinds of diseases, viruses, and we
get hurt sometimes.
So I'm all for let's let's be rational with
this.
Let's be careful.
Let's be cautious.
And let's not turn into an authoritarian regime
that forces shots and arms of people that
don't want it.
Speaker 1: Remember during the passage and
debate and the promotion of Obamacare prior
to its passing?
Remember the Republican conspiracy theory
and the talking point that Obama was going
to empanel a group of individuals to choose
who lives and dies because of the ultimate
rationing of health care that was sure to
happen.
Death panels, they called him.
Remember that?
Also, remember and note that there are no
death panels and we have Obamacare.
But secondly, that same Republican Party is
now the same all death panels, they're going
to be killing us.
That same party is now.
Who cares if your grandma dies, Snowflake?
Everybody dies.
We're human.
Get used to it.
Reprehensible hypocrisy.
The the stark lack of empathy in Republicans
is, it seems to me, to be so widespread that
maybe it's itself infectious, a contagion
that needs to be dealt with because they don't
give a shit.
They don't care about America or Americans.
All they care about is their grip on power.